let's pull this story up here we got
from the la times
in um i don't know what would you call
this irony a total irony l.a times
writes californians and other americans
are flooding mexico city some locals
want them to go home many such cases
amazing sure fernando busta uh bustos
gorozpi was sitting with friends in a
cafe when he realized that once again
they were outnumbered we're the only
brown people said bustos a 38 year old
writer we're the only people speaking
spanish except the waiters it's the
great replacement
it's a great replacement that's what i
thought was the funniest like we're the
only people speaking spanish here we
feel cut out of our own huh the influx
which accelerated
medicine
well but it's not mexico it's people
coming from guatemala honduras they're
coming from south america they're coming
from africa i totally agree i mean it's
more than just
mexicans coming across the southern
border but this highlights the point oh
so you don't like it okay
most are against people coming to
america too like mexicans they they
typically are really against illegal
immigration yeah they they were they
were really angry that the central
americans were coming no mexico right so
what we're really seeing is that
what i think you'll see from this is
that people who love their countries who
work hard and support their nation
regardless of their cultural background
their ethnic background don't like it
when other people come to where they are
and disrupt their way of life
and americans were doing this because of
coven people were leaving the united
states because of the lockdowns and the
restrictions and mexico was freer yeah
and so now they're like they're coming
here they're bringing their problems
with them it's it's i don't i don't i
see it as ironic
in that it's the americans leaving i see
it as perfectly
predictable that citizens of mexico city
would be upset that other people from a
different country are coming into their
country and changing their way of life
nationalism isn't a bad thing
yeah i think one of the most important
things even if you're talking about
globalism you need to have sovereign
national borders yes because people need
to be able to set their own laws based
on their cultures and their ways of life
if if there are if there are people who
uh there are people who want a one-world
government right it will never happen if
borders are dissolved because people
will be fighting with each other
endlessly it's the same as in
nationalism you need statehood because
you can't have a national police force
on every street corner you got to have
local laws just like in a global force
you need national levels people who
understand the local community problems
how to solve them you can't solve them
what a shocking
yeah but i mean like even thinking about
this is kind of funny you know we don't
have uh borders between states in the
way that countries do and so what
happens when someone from michigan
looking for work goes to new york people
keep flooding to the cities because
cities have jobs and their their areas
don't that hurts everyone involved
so if if you had actually borders which
were more difficult to cross over when
michigan's economy started breaking
because the auto industry was leaving
you wouldn't have the mass exodus which
means the economy may have gotten hurt
but could have recovered much more
quickly with more people requiring
services and working for each other
instead families left in insane numbers
and then the economy just buckles and
collapses because there's no one left to
support the mission
to support the state so this idea of
like multinationalism i guess it would
be like
multi-state-ism i don't know like
multinationalism would be like when a
corporation has their headquarters in
the united states but all their
production or that bunch of production
is overseas out of the united states so
like
maybe you live in in michigan but you
work in minnesota or something like that
it's legal and it's totally fine and
acceptable but when you see
multinationals i'm like that's pretty
destructive they don't have any
allegiance to the united states even
though they're raking in all the
benefits of tax laws
this has always been one this was one of
my frustrations with the 2017 tax bill
that i thought it favored the
corporations too much over the small
businesses because these corporations
were not america first they have no
inherent loyalty to this country exactly
they're trying to get the best tax rate
they can get and take advantage of the
tax system but there's no inherent
loyalty and we should have we
i made this complaint to the white house
we should have had more
favorable terms for the small businesses
because
half of the half the workforce is small
business what do you think about the
idea of like a global minimum tax for
corporations
like this international treaties where
it's like we the idea i guess is that a
company in the united states will be
like we're going to move our
headquarters to this country all right
to get a tax break right
so the idea is yeah if all these
countries come agree to a treaty it'll
stop the corporations from moving it'll
stop moving and getting yeah i don't
know if i've given a ton of thought to
it i don't think i'm opposed to in
principle but i think you know yeah
right i haven't given enough thought to
it i'm someone's going to point out in
the chat like here's a ridiculous
problem that will arise from there
probably but there is an issue that um
you know corporations move their
headquarters wherever they can to save
their tax money so they're basically
ripping us off yeah well that was not
that i'm a big fan of taxes across the
board to be honest no of course yeah no
um i think that's something that we
could have a conversation about across
the board of including property taxes
which i find deeply offensive
let's read let's read some more of the
sally time story because i do think it's
kind of funny they say at lardo a
mediterranean restaurant where on any
given night three quarters of the tables
are filled with foreigners a mexican man
in a well-cut suit recently took a seat
at the bar gazed at the english language
menu before him and he sighed as he
handed it back a menu in spanish please
huh
this is just
it's it's how is this real life
i don't know if the li times
i'm not sure they fully comprehended
what they were writing yeah i vibe with
this so hard i grew up in surrey bc if
anyone knows like the area that i grew
up in is like 70 immigrant now
it's pretty wild and you go to some
places and it's like i literally can't
order food here because no one speaks
english it's just like but if i say that
i'm a racist if la times writes about
someone who's brown having the exact
same experience as me because we're all
human and we all enjoy being able to
speak with other humans around us and
being able to read our menu suddenly
it's not racist when someone else has
the exact same internal experience go to
wild go to any country and i assure you
if say you're in turkey
and you hear someone speaking a north
america you hear them speaking english
it doesn't matter what their accent or
dialect is they're speaking english
i assure you you're going to see someone
else be like hey you speak english where
are you from right i was i was in turkey
and i was in there this this tower on i
think it's on the great horn or whatever
it's called it's like an old watch tower
and it's a tourist attraction i went up
there and everyone's speaking foreign
languages and then i hear two people
speaking with a north american dialect
and then i was like hey are you
americans and they're like no canadians
and i was like good enough what's going
on what are you doing like hey someone i
can talk to and then we talked and
it was fun that was it yeah end of story
it was like hey you know i can what are
you doing here you know it was
it's wild it's wild to me that you know
like the left always talk about getting
mad about the great replacement in like
a racial context right but it's like you
guys don't even acknowledge how
damaging it is to have so many people
come in who just don't speak the same
language like language is the only way
we can connect as human beings do
business educate each other
love each other common values
you guys won't even acknowledge the
importance of that imagine you went to
criminal court
charged the crime
and no one's and no one was speaking
everyone's speaking a different language
and struggling in the community that's
what happened to amanda knox that's she
was actually released from italian
prison but her thing was that they
didn't under it was like the language
barrier was so harsh that they just
threw the book at her and was like she's
a foreigner they're doing it now with
brittany griner so apparently the story
was she doesn't speak russian and her
lawyer was barely translating what was
going on and she had no idea what was
happening so they she kept amanda knox
kept repeating herself saying the same
thing because that's all she knew how to
say and the the italians took that as
she's definitely guilty um
you know yeah
yeah dangerous language barrier i'm a
huge advocate of bringing it doesn't
have to be english but a common language
to earth i i'm surprised it hasn't
happened i think the internet sorry we
messed that up all already in 2003 tower
of battle
they put it all in yeah place so when
that the bat the tower got blown up it
was lost but like if it was diaspora and
like everywhere you know stored in orbit
underground in everyone's bedroom like
everyone's got their data
maybe there's some value to it but the
problem is if you lose other language
because other language gives you
reference that you don't get in english
like certain the word like groomer like
it has an english definition but when
you when you talk about what that means
like groom a dog in other languages it
takes on other connotations and you need
that out external reference to get a
fuller picture yeah so they're obviously
anyone who's ever tried to teach someone
another language knows we say things
that seemingly make no sense idioms yeah
what's up
like
what does that even mean you're asking
you're asking someone what are you
currently doing and what's happening in
your life right that's like oh it's it's
such a
sup
so if someone is trying to learn english
and you you tell them what's up they'll
look at the ceiling look at the lights
they don't understand that context in in
cultural language so it's like you got
to learn that stuff too
there's there's so much in in language
that people don't understand is rel
relevant uh uh or requires personal
experience of the thing yeah especially
feelings
you know there there are many languages
that have words for feelings that are
really hard to explain to an english
speaker because they've not experienced
it without that you know understanding
yeah it's weird and we've simplified a
lot of things like obviously the word
love we that's just love we just use it
for everything sexual love familial love
we just throw it in one word but then
you have the greek um greek version
which has like you know 12 or something
philadelphia if you get that love is
love statement that ridiculous statement
in the in the pedophile or whatever
community the map the minor attracted
person community and it's like no erotic
love eros is a specific kind of love
it's not familial did you just call it
the minor attracted community yeah i
would hate that yeah
i just noticed there's the um there's
the medical uh psychedelic practices the
maps thing and then there's the map
minor attractive person have you seen
that map is like the uh
the maps is like a psychedelic uh
studies program i'm gonna pull it up
well let's i've missed it anyway sorry
yeah i missed it all right thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there